I asked artificial intelligence to write
me a recipe that would go viral and it
came up with Coca-Cola spaghetti which
like I had to try it started out pretty
normal I just added some onions garlic
and Thyme to a pan but then it told me
to add in a full bottle of Coca-Cola the
recipe said that after 10 minutes this
would boil down into a thick reduction
but it actually took me around 45
minutes for it to reduce down and it
started smelling a little bit weird like
burnt sugar so I just ended up adding it
to my cooked spaghetti when I got syrupy
and then like the recipe said I added in
some parm and parsley and got ready to
try it I was definitely nervous but I
tried it and suffice to say I was
shocked it tasted kind of good just like
a normal balsamic spaghetti I don't know
maybe there's something to that balsamic
vinegar Coke Tick Tock Trend anyways I
guess we'll see if this actually goes
viral